I do I do  it's so exciting I'm still pinching  myself I mean I'm right here I'm  standing here in Hollywood at a Steven  Spielberg premiere of you know ready  player one yeah life just didn't get  much better than that have you worked  with Steven Spielberg I mean I want to  also talk about ant-man the biggest  difference between the comics and the  movie is that of course that ghost is a  woman in the films how cool was it to  gender swap this character so cool I  mean I always say a character from a  comic book is a character from a comic  book and as an actor you are lifting it  off the page you're the one who's  creating and giving it life and yeah I  mean badass kick-ass women what's the  reaction been what kind of reaction I  mean I know people haven't I mean the  reaction has been excitement and  anticipation you know and it's that's  exactly how I feel I'm like right let's  let's see this let's do this  [Music]  you